For
the shortest meaning of Ebru, we can say that it is a water surface
art, it
always means water, crusi means face
, paints are sprinkled on a consistency of water, and it can be
transferred to many different matte surfaces
. This fabric can be wood ceramic or
many different materials
One step strange moon I paint on water
[Music]
I remember I know that I always paint as far as
I know. He was born in
a village near Hasankeyf in eastern Turkey, and there
was also an important place under the sun.
Actually,
I grew up with water since I was a child and
since then I have been trying to play all the games I can with water
[Music]
is one of the oldest records we have reached.  According to this, it is known that this
art came to Istanbul from Iran about 20 years ago.
Many known Ebru
artists live in Turkey today, and
we see that this art contains the traditions and beliefs of this country, for example, Ebru Delale is an important
symbol It represents God
subscriber  Be
You
, Ebru has its own unique materials.
The sela brush is a material that is made by hand, the
body part can be from rose branches and alternative
materials, and the other one
is made from horse tail.
Thus, a higher
amount of
paint is kept on
the brush.
it makes
it stick
to a piece of paper
.  you are doing something
fezsiz You just realize that it is a part of this process
and here
you have to have the flexibility to transform the exact form in your mind against countless possibilities
.
[Music]
and I am sure that this art
will become a discipline that is starting to be made more easily with simpler materials in many parts of the world
[Music]
subscribe